tutti ragazzi più o meno di questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo tra tutti i suoi
lavori ma sti ragazzi che hanno [ __ ]
non hanno questo potrebbe essere un
problema
ha infilato la testa nel cesso infinita
testa nel cesso melari dai italiano out
nonno sei qua per caso c'è un
appuntamento per la testa di un porco ma
va bene prendiamo infilare la testa in
tutti i pertugi sociali ci sei fatta in
fibra nel culo
su questa roba salve il progettone
quello di campo merda merda su che sono
dentro un cinghiale tu non puoi
mangiarvi perché sei vegano la coppa
dove vai ferma veramente volete dirmi
che non mi ha mangiato perché sono
vegana ragazzo grazie vegano evolène ho
capito di merda solo dentro il frigo
cos'è sta roba insomma razioni nel
dubbio non mangiare le uova possibile
delle uova
l'uomo l'uomo perfetto deve cucinare
qualcosa probabilmente però non so cosa
mi chiamo c'è un paio di credo che sia
la parte di gioco dove devo cucinare
ragazzi però si sono affidati alla
persona sbagliata perché io di cucina me
ne intendo tanto quanto cicciolina si
intende di suore per capire se c'era
l'altra nora che ne so io l'ho trovato i
fiammiferi fantastico il coltello
ho preso suo prezzo sul monte piazzo by
ma visto no no ma che cosa orribile ma
veramente sono morto ragazzi è stato
tristissimo traccia qua c'è un libro di
cucina ma lo posso usare a mi dice cosa
devo fare o che devo fare la torta a
questa torta qui che schifo [ __ ]
nel cestino si gioca non mi ha preso ma
cosa ma sono entrato lì ma come fate a
vedermi non ci posso credere mai non mi
ha visto
ma com'è possibile devo cucinare con le
salsicce prima che non c'ho le salsicce
ma [ __ ] ma che ne so io che ho
capito già abbiamo
sun albergo e io che merda ma che erano
larve non erano salsicce bello ball boy
ha detto no al colesterolo e si alle
larve e fantastico ho tutto ho tutto
quello che dovevo solo andare a cucinare
fantastico amico mio lo chef aviv per
cucinare un piatto che anche massa certo
bisogna uova ci sono farina larve che lo
fa ma devo dare con l'accendino tutto se
se se si sta cuocendo ragazzo perfetto
spiegare come mai paura che che torta
malvagità magna sala magna ragazzi sto
sta bagnando sapere si gode la lega o
mio dio
ma se i seri cucina lo zio favi legato
all'arresto per tutti behrami veramente
è sempre e comunque più salutare nel
mcdonald di questo sicuro proporta era
come dove lei messo come il cibo fammi
capire alla fin fine me lo sono mangiato
io tizio è stato il contrario
fantastico uno spazio a domandare a
cagare e giustamente è ovvio bravi mi
scappò raccordare non non devi scureggia
per aria non è che se sta tranquillo ci
arriviamo tra i resisti resisti
so che ti stai a gandosso io lo so io io
lo sapevo comunque prima o poi sarebbe
servito al cesso cioè io ero senza dubbi
proprie hai mangiato un po all'arrosto
grosso 20 volte te grazie al cazzo
questo eccesso ma non è che vai che
bagni puliti ma guarda come si usa
preparati per la
cioè si sta scorsa bluff cosa che hai
mangiato un cadavere ragazzi prende vita
lo stronzo prende vita lo stronzo ho
fatto uno stronzo con e non so è nemica
è cagato un collo vivo giorno ai cenoni
di natale mia nonna cucina talmente
tanto che è la stessa cosa cercava
uguale non poteva lavarmi le mani
giustamente non tardare a toccarmi ti
denuncio ok cosa amici è successo vabbè
tiriamo giù regate riesco scusa zio
crepato la faccia non volevo credimi ave
certo adesso adesso sì che bello pulito
6 stordito dal deodorante zio fai cadere
gli oggetti che stanno su bravo a farlo
di nuovo per favore urla bravissima
sì mi è caduto grazie la posso smettere
di urlare ogni tre secondi dai fastidio
grazie mille
abbiamo un pezzo di tubo che dovrò
infilare non so dove a ecco lo hanno
messo gira gira gira gira veloce veloce
adesso funziona devono farmi le mani dai
che se le mani sporche di merda la tua
luca fuori stronzone verso il corpo
stronzone di confrontarmi facebook cos'è
che schifati rossetti lo lascia fuori
rosa cuore non lo tiro perché si incazza
lo tira l'acqua mentre distratto anzi
quasi
se ce l'ho fatta stoffa no non ci credo
è tornato su mamma se vedi le pareti
sporche di merda non sono stato io giuro
e colori né fuori dice no no no vi è
risucchiato accesso ma perché è
veramente ci credo mai il bagno sporco
di merda ci mancava solo che finissimo
lo sciacquone fantastico nostro nostro
figlio ho perso dovrei farlo a non ha
perso ma no si ricorda pazza si ricordi
rai per caso ho fatto un giro bene le
fogne con tuo nonno ha fatto un giro per
le foglie con suo nonno ragazzi questo
tipo mi sorprendo ogni volta di più sono
curioso di sapere come continua perché
non non so come sono finito scaricato
nel cesso expo fare parte di cio la
zampa sono il cane ma dai è che cassano
controllo il cane così può fare devo
fare
chissà gioco tutti cagano scoreggia non
i quattro secondi e soffrite tutti di
flautolenze fatemi capire come ti sei
permesso a rana della minkia acqua più
albero uguale rape questa è una rapa
spero voi non lo so
e va beh ho capito lo si fa mito quindi
devo trovare dell'acqua ragazzi sta
diventando così starò a dovevo
semplicemente innaffiarlo ragazzino
avevo capito e quindi adesso restano
spingo le rape sull'arena così la rana
mangia le rape e non mi rompe le parole
giuste
sì se l'è presa se l'è presa
cos'è cos'è non pensavo fosse una rapa
radioattiva zio e mi spiace però fai
sempre bastardo hai finito di mangiare
ste cagate ceo ed ho trovato un nuovo
astronauta per la nasa la terra e salva
perfetto ragazzi siamo siamo a posto
finito devo solo trovare l'esca che crea
ecco qua sotto
ce l'abbiamo devo farla arrivare fino
alla fine cioè non è che posso prenderlo
devo spaventarla salta sulla barca in
data sulla barca perfetto a sul lago
proprio perfetto hai fatto tutto tu ed
io abbiamo fatto niente non solo
guardato credi sera come lo sapevo lo us
app e io lo giuro lo sapevo bellissimo
però piacciono un sacco tra l'altro però
non ho capito perché poche domande
ragazzi erano rimasti che ecco infatti
stavo cadendo quindi qualcosa qualcosa
dovrò pur fare perché esso è rimasto
così quella che belle merde galleggianti
un coccodrillo che minchia di fogna
somma che fogne sono fatemi capire
sono sveglio sono sveglio mi ha
rianimato
cosa è successo posso muovermi posso
rotolare ragazzi sono ancora vivo perchè
mi ha fatto l'elettroshock che cura
quindi è rotto rotolando penso di
potermi salvare partition le merde
galleggianti che schifo un calzino
bellissimo ragazzi non posso fare così
niente perché devo rotolare basta
profilo c'è un opossum e di preciso dove
devo arrivare che non a caso devo
riuscire ad andare avanti senza toccare
gli ostacoli perfetto ho capito penso di
potercela fare da che credo a queste
sono le fogne di casa mia ragazza un
coccodrillo prime live ai muri di vermi
no no eh vabbè impossibile come non
ridete più me ne mancano due ragazzi
devo di ucciderne 2 anno se non si sono
fidati volendo si è fatta altro forum
e vabbè che cosa c'è godzilla nel mio
scarico che schifo c'è l'uccello di
angri bars morto è ingigantito
leggermente vada con un dettaglio
siamo qua c'è un pesce morto a il pesce
di prima però sono morto io comunque c'è
dal verme non avevo visto il pesce che
avevo pescato prima come l'abbiamo
buttato nel cesso alla fine ragazzi qua
è perfetto adesso guarda questo passare
guardano giovedì bene comune quale
utilità cia stop esce fammi capire cosa
posso fare con un pesce non ci credo non
ci voglio non ci voglio credere sono
diventato un pesce è bellissimo adesso
posso andare dove voglio perché nuoto
come fosse un paese fantastico no perché
sono sempre comunque un deficiente una
spada ma per chi fa una star
va beh cos'è sta roba giorno è una
balena morta fantastico vabbè se capita
tutti i giorni i ragazzi però e balene
morte soprattutto se cago polli arrosto
dio
e va beh un po di più potete mandarmi
cosa ho fatto tu vai spostatevi luridi
spostatevi cosa ho fatto via via via via
via via via via via via via via via via
via via che va beh ma quanti sono
impossibile il morta se non so come ho
fatto non ho idea non fate domande non
lo so ho fatto rope robe a caso va bene
così sfuggito all ira delle larve vabbè
che casino tra schifo come passo di qua
va bene ha commentato non mi segue
ragazzi sia uscito non pensavo pensavo
di morire
in questo video è sempre cosa rivi vabbè
se leggermente nella merda zio però
arriva il coccodrillo scommetto perché è
una roba di questo non è un [ __ ]
coccodrillo che cosa vita anche altri
ragazzi concludo che l'episodio lo so
che vorreste scoprire che cos'è il ma io
sono stronzo e con quello più l'episodio
spero che vede vi sia piaciuto mi piace
farla cacchiata enorme che quella merita
tutto il video secondo me credo e poi
non so i ragazzi servillo è piaciuto ma
sarebbe stato come detto è un mi piace
anche a face di facebook e come vi va
fatta eccezione i soliti schemi ci
vediamo il bel rialzo